وبالعودة إلى الأسبوع الأول من الصراع
في 10 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول، على وجه الدقة،
أجرينا مقابلة مع حنين أوكال، وهي
امرأة من ولاية نيوجيرسي ولديها ثلاثة أطفال يبلغ
عمر أحدهم شهرين فقط، وكانوا مجرد عدد قليل
من مئات الأمريكيين الذين أمضوا
ما يقرب من شهر محاصرين في  غزة كانت
تزور عائلتها في الشمال عندما
هاجمت حماس، ثم بناءً على طلب وزارة
الخارجية، انتقلت حنين وأطفالها
جنوبًا نحو معبر رفح،
ولعدة أيام انتظرت عائلة أوكال
وانتظرت وانتظرت حتى نفاد الطعام والماء،
وتقاسمت مكانًا للمأوى  مع حوالي
40 شخصًا، بما في ذلك شقيق حنين أبو
عال الذي كان أيضًا في غزة والذي أخبرناكم بقصته
أيضًا، وفي الأسبوع الماضي،
سمحت صفقة وسيط لعائلتي أوكال
بمغادرة غزة وقد عادوا إلى
أرضنا منذ حوالي 48 ساعة
وانضم إلي هان أول  الآن من
منزلها في نيوجيرسي هانين يسعدني جدًا
أن ألقي التحية عليك في نيوجيرسي مرحبًا بعودتك
إلى الولايات المتحدة كيف حالك
كيف حال أطفالك اه لقد أخبرتنا أن
الطفل سيستيقظ في الليل
بسبب الهواء  الضربات اه كيف
حال الطفل شكرا جزيلا جاك نعم نحن
بخير الحمد لله لقد وصلنا إلى هنا
إلى اه نيوجيرسي نحن بخير اه
أفضل بكثير
مما كنا عليه عندما كنا في غزة أطفالي
بخير هم  أنا سعيد جدًا برؤية والدهم،
زوجي سعيد جدًا برؤيتنا
كما كان، كان خائفًا من أنه
لن يتمكن من رؤيتنا مرة أخرى على الإطلاق،
لذا وصلنا إلى هنا في نيوجيرسي
ولا أستطيع ذلك  حتى تصدق ذلك حتى هذه اللحظة،
لا أستطيع أن أصدق ما مررنا به ولكن
أخيرًا نحن هنا والطفل بخير،
الطفل بخير، كما تعلم لم يكن هناك
يوم لم نكن نتصل فيه أو نرسل
رسائل نصية للناس  بالنيابة عنك
حتى خروجك آه كنا على هذه
القضية طوال الوقت أخبرنا عن
تلك الأيام القليلة الماضية في غزة
وتجربتك في الخروج كيف كان الأمر
أخيرًا والوصول إلى
مصر كان الأمر صعبًا للغاية آه نحن  خرجوا من
رفح إلى
الحدود أم إلى الجانب الفلسطيني أولا
ثم أه الجانب الفلسطيني أه
شاهدوا أسمائنا في القائمة أه وبعد ذلك
يتحققون من كلمات المرور وبعد ذلك
أه يرسلوننا إلى الجانب المصري أه
الجانب المصري هم  عندما ذهبنا
إلى هناك قاموا بالتحقق من أسمائنا وبعد ذلك اه اه
قالوا كل شيء على ما يرام ولكن في
حالتي أه مع ابني إيلاس تعلم
أن ابني لم يكن لديه جواز سفر
لأنني اضطررت إلى تسليمه في غزة
اه بسبب اه  حالتي الطبية لقد
اضطررت إلى ولادته منذ شهرين آه
لم أتمكن من العودة لإبقائه هنا هنا
أثناء زيارتي
لعائلتي لذلك للأسف لم يكن لدي جواز سفر آه
حاولنا لأننا حاولنا كثيرًا
الاتصال بـ  كان لدي موعد مع سفارة الولايات المتحدة في القدس في
الطائف حتى
حدثت الحرب وبعد ذلك لم أتمكن من
الذهاب إلى هناك لأنهم مثل
حدود ARS، لقد تم ضخها لذا
كان الأمر بائسًا ولم أستطع الحصول عليها  هل توجد
طريقة للحصول على جواز سفر له، لذلك
اتصلنا بالسفارة الأمريكية في مصر وقد بذلوا قصارى جهدهم في
الواقع لقد
ساعدونا كثيرًا بفضلهم أه أه
طبعوا له جواز سفر طارئ
وكانوا هناك في انتظارنا في
المصري  الجانب ليعطينا
جواز السفر حتى نتمكن من إعطائه
للمصري حتى نتمكن من الدخول أم ونعم كما قلت اه
الولايات المتحدة أم السفارة الأمريكية كانت
تنتظرنا في الجانب المصري لقد
كانوا مرحبين للغاية لقد
فعلوا كل شيء  يمكنهم القيام به لمساعدة
كل مواطن أمريكي هناك في
معبر رفح الحدودي وكانوا يساعدوننا تمامًا في
كل ما يمكنهم فعله أه
يمكنني أه السفر إلى مصر بسبب هذا
لأنهم أعطوني جواز سفر
لابني  لأنه في هذه الحالة
أعتقد الآن أن المصريين يسمحون
للفلسطينيين، أعتقد أن الأمريكيين أو
أي شخص أو من خلال الولايات المتحدة، بجواز
السفر الفلسطيني لدخول مصر إذا
لم يكن لديهم جواز السفر يسمحون
لهم بالحصول على رقم الهوية ولكن في
حالتي في  الأول لأنني كنت من
الأشخاص القلائل الذين سافروا وكنت مدرجًا
في القائمة في اليوم الثاني الذي
فتحوا فيه الحدود، لذا في ذلك
الوقت كان من الصعب جدًا على الأشخاص
السفر بدون جواز سفر، نعم، لذلك
تمكنت من ذلك  يمكنني العودة إلى غزة إذا
لم أتمكن من الحصول على جواز سفر لابني
إيلاس ولم نتمكن من السفر
بدونه أه لذلك كان الأمر
مخيفًا جدًا بالنسبة لي إذا لم أتمكن من الحصول على
جواز سفر له  ابني من أجل مولودي الجديد
سأعود إلى غزة مع أطفالي الآخرين
لأننا لن نتمكن من
تركه أه حسنًا الحمد لله الحمد لله
وأصرخ للمجتهدين أه
موظفي السفارة الأمريكية في القاهرة الذين حصلوا على
هذا الجواز  لأنه أخبرني أن
هذه كانت الحالة الأولى التي فعلنا فيها هذا من
أجلهم لقد فعلوا ذلك من أجلنا وكأنها
المرة الأولى التي يحدث فيها أنهم قاموا
بطباعة جواز سفر أمريكي طارئ لك
وأن الأم ليست أه الأم أو
الأب  لا تظهر، إنها مجرد
المعلومات التي قدمتها في
الطلب وهذا كل شيء ولكن
لا يمكنني أن أشكرهم بما فيه الكفاية لقد قاموا
بعمل شاق، نعم حسنًا، إنه فتى مميز،
إنه فتى صغير مميز، لذا بعض القواعد
كان يجب أن ينكسر من أجله أنا أنا
سعيد لأنه حدث كشخص
كان محاصرا في غزة طوال تلك الأسابيع
يجب أن أسألك أم الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية
أه إسرائيل تدعي أنها
تستهدف حماس  رأيت أين
كانوا يقصفون أه هل يبدو أنهم
كانوا يستهدفون أهدافا محددة لحماس
أم يبدو أنهم
كانوا يقصفون
بشكل
عشوائي أه بجد لا أعلم لا أحد يعرف
هناك لأن الارتطام في جميع أنحاء
الغارات الجوية حول المدينة  في جميع أنحاء
الجنوب، في كل مكان تتصل به،
تتصل بأقاربك في قانون أو أه آنا أو
أو في رع، جميعهم يقولون أن
مناطقهم أصبحت مزعجة، لذلك لا أحد يعرف
تمامًا أنهم يصطدمون بحماس ولكن
لا أحد يعرف إذا كانت حماس فقط لأنهم
يريدون الوصول  حماس بأي
طريقة ممكنة تعرفها ولكن الطريقة التي يفعلون
بها لا أعرف ما إذا كانت هذه هي الطريقة الصحيحة
لأنها ستصل إلى
نقطة تعرفها بشكل تمييزي
كما لو أنه لا أحد يعرف ذلك نعم
بجدية لا يزال لديك  عائلتي في غزة
ماذا سمعت منهم هل
سمعت منهم على الاطلاق
نعم حتى اليوم هكذا حاولت
أحاول الآن أحاول قصارى جهدي للحصول على
بقية عائلتي لأن لدي
أخوات تركت هناك إخوتي اه أمي
وأبي لا يزال هناك لا أستطيع أن
أصدق أنك تعلم أن قلبي مكسور
لأنني نعم وصلت إلى هنا وأنا مع
أطفالي وأنا مع عائلتي نحن
بخير لكنني لست سعيدًا لأن
عائلتي  هل هناك وصدق أو لا تصدق
بقية عائلتي يريدون
الخروج للخروج من غزة يريدون أن
يفعلوا ذلك، فمنازلهم منزعجة لذا
حتى لو انتهت الحرب أه ليس لديهم
مكان يعودون إليه  كما تعلمون،
الأمر صعب حقًا لأن الطعام الآن هناك
معاناة، إنهم
يعانون حقًا، لا يوجد طعام كافٍ لكل
شخص يأكلون الطعام المعلب،
لا يوجد ما يكفي من
الماء، لا كهرباء، لا إنترنت حتى
الآن مع الطاقة الشمسية،
اه القطبية، الطاقة الشمسية  النظام،
إنهم يشعرون بالانزعاج، كما تعلمون، لذا
لا يوجد ما هو صحيح، الأمر صعب حقًا هناك،
إنه بائس حقًا، لا أعرف ما إذا كان
أي إنسان يمكنه العيش هناك،
أشعر بالحزن الشديد لجميع أبناء العمومة، ليس فقط
أفراد عائلتي ولكن لجميع
أبناء العمومة  لا أعرف كيف سيتمكنون من
تحقيق ذلك بعد كل هذا، كن على علم بالبقاء
على اتصال معنا لأننا نريد أن
نستمر ونريد أن نستمر في متابعة الأمر، أعلم
أنك آمن وأعلم أن أطفالك الثلاثة
آمن وأنا أعرف أخيك AB
الذي روينا قصته أيضًا آمنًا
ولكن من الواضح أنه لا يزال هناك
ملايين من الفلسطينيين الأبرياء الذين
ليسوا كذلك ونريد أن نبقى على اطلاع
بالأمر ولكننا سعداء لأنك
أنت كذلك  عودة حنين، نحن حقًا
سعداء جدًا بعودتك، لذا شكرًا
جزيلاً لك على الانضمام إلينا